quand on se prépare pour une sortie en
ville on peut pas se voir dans le miroir
bien sûr puisqu'on et les vampires alors
du coup on utilise des subterfuges
j'adore c'est un peu pénible cette
histoire fait même si c'est toujours une
bonne occasion pour se faire des blagues
eh les mecs regardez phantom navire a
fait tout seul du coup le regard des
autres est hyper important pour
peaufiner nos looks y atteindre la
perfection
oui c'est vrai certains nos habits
viennent de victimes on peut très bien
su c'est quelqu'un et se dire j'adore
son pantalon
mais il est cool c'est rien c'est
horrible mais passe pour être un vampire
il faut déjà être naturellement sexy
physiquement on a l'obligation d'être au
top pour attirer nos proie alors on se
fait des petites simulation pour
inscrire on s'excite nous mêmes à la non
ça va pas je suis absolument pas
excitant fait moins peur michael jackson
pour voir pas mal
et là les filles en fait les gens ont
une image extrêmement glamour du vampire
ça fait complètement partout notre adn
c'est comme ça on n'y peut rien alors on
peut pas se permettre de décevoir nos
victimes
au bout du compte c'est une forme de
respect envers les gens qu'on va dévorer
voilà on est prêt pour aller en ville et
faire la teuf